[Music]
you're not supposed to be alive none of
us are about 10 years ago you woke up to
an eerie silence the power was out you
went to check your phone for news but
your phone was dead then you realized
everything was dead some kind of
blackout you thought you looked out your
window confused it looked like a normal
December morning holiday decorations
were up though all the Christmas lights
were out you saw Neighbors also peering
through windows and standing on their
front porches everyone was looking up
it looked like the stars were falling
only they weren't Stars they were
satellites and space debris it was
raining fire and for the first time in
your life you saw the Aurora Borealis in
the middle of the day you looked at the
calendar today's date was supposed to
mean something but before you could
remember everything went black it was
December 21st 2012 the end of the
[Music]
world
hey I was getting a game of Go Heckle
fist together you in I don't have time
to plug merch right now human I got an
emergency what's up with your voice oh
oh hang on hang
on uh being resurrected always makes me
a little mucousy resurrected it means
coming back from the dead I know what it
means what's going on the's resurrecting
tarious Warriors to fight the dark
lordge C I need you to join my clan he's
tting a shadow over the entire realm
what the hell are you talking about when
the AR needs Champions we must answer
the call that's what Heroes do wait a
minute is this today's sponsor yes rage
Shadow Legends is a super detailed
tactical RPG battle system it's got PVE
and PVP content and now you can play as
a new mythical Champion with metamor
metamorph it means you can change your
shape I know what it means now it's
amazing you can change between two
different different forms like
this oh well this is all right so click
the link in the description or scan the
QR code on the screen and get a free
started pack with cool in-game loop hey
do we have excuse me will you let me get
through the copy before you start asking
stupid questions sorry you're right go
ahead new users use promo code y ra and
get a bunch of silver extra magic and
the rare hero theist but anyone can use
code ra for all and get silver double p
and a rank up chicken did you just say
rank up chicken well that's what it says
here look it's free so click the link or
scan the QR code don't look at GI fish
in the mouth all right I'm doing it but
uh you got to change me back no can do
chief I got to keep you like this
through the weekend what why H your wife
gave me 50
[Music]
bucks in early 1948 the curator for the
national naal Museum of Iraq had a very
exciting meeting two American
archaeologists walked into his office
with a briefcase and set it gently on
his desk next to a Dusty cardboard box
the three men exchanged polite greetings
and shook hands one of the Americans
dialed a code on the case popped the
locks and opened it it was full of cash
stacks of $100 bills United States legal
tender very very nice the curator
removed the lid of what looked like an
old unmarked shoe box inside there were
two ancient Sumerian cylinder
seals the Americans were willing to pay
handsomely for these the curator wasn't
even sure why a cylinder seal is nothing
more than a tube Made of Stone or metal
engraved with a design they were used by
everybody in Sumer it was basically a
stamp you rolled the cylinder over a
document or a piece of leather the
engraving on the cylinder imprinted its
design which served as a personal
signature on a document or package it
was a way for a Samaran to guarantee
authenticity of a business deal like
signing a contract cylinder seals were
made of wood Stone bronze really
whatever the owner could afford these
specific cylinders were made of gold but
the curator was being paid much more
than their weight in gold many times
more the curator offered to show the
American archaeologists more seals
hoping for another sale there were
hundreds of them in the museum he could
make a fortune but the Americans were
only interested in these two cylinders
the curator didn't know how the
Americans even knew they existed they
weren't on display in the museum at all
they've been sitting boxed on a Dusty
shelf for years but there was so much
cash in that briefcase the curator
wasn't going to ask questions he was now
a rich man no reason to press his luck
the box and briefcase were closed the
men again shook hands and the deal was
done an hour later the archae ologists
were settled into their seats on a c97
strat fighter this particular Strat was
outfitted for passenger transport by the
recently formed United States Air Force
One of the men pulled a flask from his
coat with a sigh it was going to be a
long day refuel in London then over the
Atlantic a quick stop at Andrews in
Maryland and then finally land at
Hollowman Airfield in New Mexico he
joked with his partner that his flask
would also need refueling along the way
the other man opened the dusty shoe box
on his lap and stared at the Samarian
cylinder seals puzzled they didn't look
like anything important they reminded
him of metal toilet paper rolls the
Engravings were just the typical ancient
stuff men holding staffs people sitting
in chairs there were pictures of animals
maybe oxen and a bunch of symbols he
didn't recognize he showed the open box
to his partner who had just taken a long
belt from his flask both men Shrugged
they had no idea what they were looking
at why would they they weren't
archaeologists
[Music]
Hitler was fascinated with the occult
and ancient relics he believed these
relics were powerful and could be used
as tools to conquer Europe and Beyond
Nazi archaeologists search for The Arc
of the Covenant the box that held the
stone tablets of the Ten Commandments
according to scripture the ark was a
powerful weapon and could level entire
armies in 1940 Hinrich himler personally
led a mission to find the Holy Grail
The Grail was the cup used by Christ at
the Last Supper it said that the Grail
has the power to provide Eternal youth
Hitler was fascinated with the Spear of
Destiny this was used by Roman legionary
gas cassus longinus to pierce the side
of Christ at the
crucifixion there were German
archaeological sites all over the Middle
East hundreds of people were searching
for these artifacts now as far as we
know none of them were found but in the
late 1930s ancient Sumerian cylinder
seals were discovered
the toilet paper rose with the pitches
yeah a few of these seals were not
Samaran at all they were much older they
were given as gifts to the samarians by
their
ancestors you mean yes anunaki correct
Yi the Anunnaki arrived on Earth 500,000
years ago seeking gold to repair their
planet's atmosphere they genetically
engineered primitive humans to mine the
Gold about 12,000 years ago there was a
global cataclysm some kind of event
melted the polar ice caps and caused a
great flood this was either an asteroid
impact or more likely a major solar
event the flood caused sea levels to
rise 400 ft and changed the face of the
Earth millions of square miles of land
were submerged cities were destroyed the
entire human race was almost wiped out
you can see this flood myth depicted in
every ancient Culture The Myth usually
ends with a Godlike figure emerging from
the sea or from the sky to help man kind
restart
civilization the Anunnaki gave the
samarians instructions to escape
Extinction these instructions are carved
on the cylinder
seals when rolled in the proper sequence
the cylinders outlined a procedure to
access naturally occurring wormholes now
these are portals sometimes called
Stargates that allow you to move to
various points in space instantly and
there were about 50 of them all over the
world and since the cylinders were found
to be alien they were trans refer to a
group called Majestic
12 Majestic 12 was established in 1947
to take charge of the technical
biological and all aspects of crashed
UFOs mj12 soon learned that UFO
technology was compatible with the
information on the surian cylinders by
combining the ancient Stargate
instructions with alien technology mj12
was able to build a machine but the
machine was more powerful than anyone
could imagine it was powerful enough to
destroy the planet and in 2012 it
[Music]
did on a warm spring day in 1994 Dan
landed at homy airport in the middle of
the Nevada desert he had just taken the
weirdest flight of his life there were
hardly any passengers on the white
Boeing 737 that took off from aaren
airport in Las Vegas the few people that
were there were seated far apart and
instructed to not talk to each other
despite the strict rules the pilot was
pretty friendly over the PA he thanked
them for choosing Janet Airlines and
then joke that they really had no choice
at all then he played Coming to America
over and over again from Neil Diamond
yep everywhere around the world they
come into America you're probably just
going to every time that Flags
unfilled they come into America
today that's enough oh oh can we do love
and ARA next this guy just landed at
Area 51 and you want to do Neil diam
karaoke the human makes a good point
please
continue Dan was a microbiologist and
accepted an offer to work on a top
secret government program called project
Aquarius Aquarius operated at an
underground facility called Papo Lake on
base employees call the building S4 S4
was about 12 mi from Area 51 Dan was
taken there by a patchy helicopter he
was then escorted to the building by a
polite but very serious military officer
dressed in desert camo Dan assumed he
was an officer he wore no designation of
rank in fact his uniform had no
designations of any kind no rank no
branch no patches nothing the man didn't
even have a name patch the officer
didn't offer his name and Dan didn't ask
security measures at S4 were intense
armed guards were everywhere
every door required voice print
identification or a retinal scan every
day he'd have to go through a
decontamination procedure including a
change of clothes shower and a shave the
floors of S4 were painted with parallel
lines one blue and the other red Dan was
told to stay within the blue lines and
to never cross a red line guards were
ordered to shoot to kill anyone who
crossed a red line the good stuff is
behind the red line ain't it will you
let me paint the picture here sorry
sorry I'm just excited go ahead
S4 had five floors but you had to walk
down from level one to level four the
only elevator in the building was on
level four which was the only way in or
out of level five on level one Dan was
given his security badge and shown the
cafeteria the dining hall had four round
tables each assigned to a different
project team he was to eat with the
Aquarius team at their table meal times
were staggered to minimize contact but
he was still reminded to not speak with
members of any other project
the long hallway on level one passed a
number of Hangar Bays on Dan's left the
hangers were on the other side of the
red line I knew it the first few hangers
were empty but then Dan walked past the
hanger that changed his life forever he
saw a dis shaped object a flying saucer
later Dan would learn this was a p45
craft a few more empty hangers and then
another Flying Saucer this one was a
different type A p-52 the last hanger
held a craft shaped like a triangle it
was flat black and hovering a few feet
off the ground level three was offices
conference rooms and living quarters
level four the Aquarius floor was Dan's
new lab there he was finally read into
the project up until now he didn't know
what he'd be doing he was just told it
was exciting important and very top
secret as a microbiologist he would be
analyzing alien biology tissue samples
DNA everything H hold on you ski level
two right level two was strange it was
known as Alice's floor Alice from The
Brady Bunch no oh from M din no from
Alice and Wonderland
oh project Galileo was on this floor
that dealt with propulsion systems from
Alien aircraft level four was also home
to project sidekick and alien weapons
program on level four Dan saw a small
plastic statue hanging above a door it
was a statue of the white rabbit from
Allison Wonderland the rabbit was
wearing a red vest and holding a pocket
watch and if you follow the White Rabbit
through that door just like Alice you
step through the Looking Glass and into
another
world inside the project Looking Glass
lab was a machine the exterior of the
device was a circular ring about 5 ft
tall and 10 ft wide it's made of a dark
gray metal alloy with a smooth finish
this ring forms the outer shell inside
the circular ular outer ring is a core
made of several spinning Rings think of
the object in the movie contact it
looked just like that just on a smaller
scale these spinning Rings were lined
with powerful electromagnets these
created fluctuating electromagnetic
fields around the center chamber at the
heart of the machine was a rotating
metal Barrel lined with quartz crystals
this Central Barrel is suspended inside
the spinning rings using gyroscopes and
a gimbal mechanism and inside the barrel
is a chair for the operator to do what
well a few things it really depends on
the operator yeah follow well over time
as the technology became more understood
the machines could be adjusted to do
various things to warp SpaceTime Looking
Glass Technology was used during the
Philadelphia Experiment that project
failed but later the Mok project was
launched and researchers learned that if
a person with certain mental abilities
was integrated with the technology it
could be controlled operators learn to
see any place on Earth Earth you've
heard this called remote viewing all the
operator would have to do is think of a
place and that place could be seen and
this was useful for intelligence
gathering but it was extremely helpful
in locating more ancient Sumerian
cylinders as more cylinder seals were
discovered they added more capabilities
to the machines mj12 knew there were
more cylinders out there but the
political climate was making them harder
to acquire remember the cylinder seals
are Sumerian Sumer is now Iraq
but the United States still found ways
to access the
artifacts just 2 hours ago Allied Air
Forces began an attack on Military
Targets in Iraq and Kuwait these attacks
continue as I speak ground forces are
not engaged I'm hopeful that this
fighting will not go on for long and
that casualties will be held to an
absolute minimum we have before us the
opportunity to forge for ourselves and
for future future Generations A New
World Order world world come on the US
started a war to steal old Museum stuff
no the US military wouldn't be so
blatant and obvious for 3 days in April
2003 looters rampaged in the stor rooms
and galleries of Iraq's national museum
at this hour American and Coalition
forces are in the early stages of
military operations to disarm Iraq to
free its people and to defend the world
from grave Danger making off with some
15,000 Priceless objects these are
opening stages of what will be a broad
and concerted campaign many dated back
thousands of years to the great
civilizations of Babylon and
Mesopotamia a few years later cylinders
were found in Libya good morning and we
are interrupting Good Morning America
here on the East Coast your regular
program on the west coast because we
have learned reports from libia the
momar Gaddafi the leader of Libya for
more than 40 years has been killed by
Rebel forces
back on Alice's floor in the S4 Building
Technology from Crash UFOs was found to
be compatible with the Looking Glass
devices using this advanced technology
the Looking Glass operator could do more
than see any place on Earth the operator
could see any time on Earth the past
present and the future and if the
operator was really talented not only
could he see the future he could change
it the CIA has always been interested in
psychics and psychic abilities a psychic
who could see anywhere on Earth is the
ideal spy psychics were also useful for
Looking Glass devices in the 1980s
and90s psychics were recruited or
abducted for this purpose a chair
recovered from an extraterrestrial craft
had technology that let the pilot sink
his Consciousness with the craft this
technology was integrated into the
Looking Glass machines the psychic
operator would sit in the chair at the
center of the Looking Glass device and
activate the machine the startup
sequence charged the electromagnets
surrounding the central core that were
calibrated in specific ways depending on
the mission then Xenon and Argon gas
were injected into the rotating Barrel a
grayish orb would form in front of the
operator within the gas this was a
stable Wormhole to the probability
Dimension that sounds made up but I love
it what the hell are you talking about
the Looking Glass machine allowed the
user to see past present and future
seeing the past is interesting but
seeing the future that's useful but not
only could you see the future you could
see possibilities of the future the
operator would mentally focus on an
action the operator could then see the
probable outcome of this action like
what would happen if we invaded this
country or what would happen if this
particular person was
assassinated the output was captured by
cameras and relayed to view screens the
researchers could feed questions to the
operator and instantly see the results
this was highly useful
what they reported seeing covered an
enormous range from disaster events and
weather anomalies to political outcomes
and Earth changes soon Looking Glass
operators learned how to steer events
toward a specific goal there was a
problem though different operators would
see different things depending on their
own biases like a Christian looking
backwards will see the crucifixion of
Christ atheists would just see Jerusalem
looking forward was the same problem
operators were seeing different future
outcomes
physicists and computer scientists were
brought in to develop software to
stabilize the process computer programs
could feed the operator a lot of
questions very quickly and the results
would come back fast it worked and it
was useful for a few years thousands of
choices were fed to operators and
thousands of possible timelines were
seen but in the late 1990s mj12 and its
scientists became very nervous they had
many different psychic operators seeing
all kinds of different future events but
none of them can see anything past 2012
specifically December 21st 2012 the
Mayan calendar ends on that date all
timelines converged on that date and
then nothing there was nothing after
that ah this isn't a good sign it's not
but the scientists had help not only did
they have a p-52 spacecraft they had the
pilot they called him a p-52 as in
present plus 52 he was from 52,000 years
in the future holy sh and the p-52 alien
he was
[Music]
human on May 21st 1953 a team of Air
Force scientists were sent to a UFO
crash site 8 miles Northwest of Kingman
Arizona one of these scientists was
Arthur stanzel who signed an affidavit
stating that he was an eyewitness to the
Kingman UFO recovery operation the craft
had a brushed aluminum exterior and was
about 30 ft F feet wide inside were
swivel seats instruments and display
panels Witnesses saw several bodies they
were about 4 ft tall with dark skin they
had small bodies and big heads with
large black eyes one of these beings was
alive and taken to Area 51 he was from
52,000 years in the future so he was
classified a p-52 bang bang
bang baby bang bang I can't hear you
bang you know prefer their earliest
stuff you rock lobster Planet clear yeah
me too the p-52 alien was nicknamed jrod
jrod sounds like a hip-hop artist or
basketball player well his personal name
was kyela jrod was his race specifically
Kaa was a p-52 jrod got it kyela was
based in the glea system in the
direction of the constellation Aquarius
that's how project Aquarius got its name
now although he was based in glea KY was
originally from The Zeta reticuli system
Zeta reticuli is well known to UFO
researchers in 1961 Betty and Barney
Hill were abducted by beings who said
they were from Zeta reticuli Betty
wasn't an astronomer or scientist of any
kind still she was able to draw a star
map of Zeta reticuli which is a binary
star system her map also includes glea
ky's people were dealing with an illness
that was devastating the population his
crew was one of many sent back in time
to Earth to try to find a cure the p-52
alien are somewhat genetically
compatible with humans in their timeline
they're an offshoot of homo sapiens KY
was eventually allowed to go home but he
spent years at Area 51 he helped save
Humanity from destruction in
2012 but mj12 didn't realize that the
2012 apocalyptic event wasn't an
accident it was supposed to happen it
was engineered to
happen you another race of future
humans
the Stargate technology on the surian
cylinders is said to be a gift to
humanity but it's not a gift it's a
weapon and on a different timeline it
destroyed us there's a timeline where on
December 21st 2012 a disaster took place
there was a massive geophysical pole
shift of almost 5° the shift was caused
by the Earth's upper mantle reacting to
a massive explosion of energy from the
Sun
this shift caused the chain reaction in
the earth's tectonic plates the Earth
trembled with an intensity never before
recorded cities near the epicenters of
these shifts were the first to feel the
effects buildings designed to withstand
earthquakes crumbled like sand castles
the seismic waves radiated outward
reaching every part of the planet no one
was safe as the crust shifted it wasn't
just land that was affected under the
ocean the violent movement of the seabed
caused enormous tsunamis coastal cities
were obliterated by walls of water
rushing at tremendous speeds Inland the
story was just as Grim landslides and
sink holes swallowed entire towns
mountains that had stood for millions of
years crumbled in other places land was
thrust upward creating new mountain
ranges dormant volcanoes came to life
with explosive eruptions the atmosphere
around the entire planet was filled with
Ash the sky went
black
in the aftermath the Earth was
unrecognizable the geography of the
continents was completely different some
land masses fractured into Islands other
land masses merged new Seas were created
from cracks in the earth some ancient
Rivers changed course others were just
gone country struggled to assess the
damage and coordinate Aid critical
infrastructure was destroyed and Global
Communication networks no longer
functioned this Global cataclysm killed
2/3 of the world's population and led to
the extinction of many species the
surface of the Earth was in ruin the
volcanic ash had poisoned the atmosphere
and blocked sunlight for years the
entire food chain collapsed but humans
didn't go extinct the survivors went
underground and rebuilt
civilization over thousands of years our
ability to manipulate time and space
grew more and more powerful we could
alter our DNA in real time we can
manipulate our physical form the form
that was most beneficial for surviving
underground was a smaller thinner body
our brains grew larger so did our skulls
large dark eyes helped us see in the
darkness we became what are described as
the Grays the Grays we see now aren't
aliens they're us 45,000 years in the
future Majestic 12 calls them
p45s p45s future human humans were able
to unlock a lot of potential from the
human brain they learned telepathic
communication and how to manipulate
space and time with thought but this
Evolution had a downside future humans
lost their Humanity they became
emotionless and cold they became selfish
drones interested only in serving their
own needs people who've been abducted by
Grays describe them exactly like this
uncaring and almost robotic they're
experimenting on humans to improve their
own future
the experiments focus on human DNA
analysis and how that can be spliced
with p45 DNA or even other animals DNA
in order to improve their own genetic
future but here's where it gets scary
the p45 Grays wanted that cataclysm to
happen in 2012 they still want it they
need it to happen so they can come into
existence yeah but it didn't happen no
it didn't kyela the p-52 alien had the
Looking Glass machines turned off for a
few years why well it was using this
technology that created the disaster in
2012 the artificial wormholes were
disrupting the magnetic energy of the
Sun so we're safe now right oh no we're
not safe we're not safe at
[Music]
all the Grays either are or are
controlling the Illuminati the
Illuminati still want this disaster to
happen fewer people on the planet means
they have more control eat bugs live in
a pod owe nothing and be happy exactly
and keep people terrified of
overpopulation by controlling world
leaders and use the media to disseminate
propaganda all to create fear so hatred
and ideally lead us to nuclear
war there is another timeline split
coming in 2030 one timeline shows
Humanity Awakening this timeline ushers
in a new era of Peace Humanity learns
telepathy and all the lies we've been
told are suddenly revealed if you have
questions about who killed JFK or what
happened on 911 you'll know every
deception will be exposed like a cloud
lifting from over our entire species or
there's the other timeline where there's
a
[Music]
disaster and if you're lucky enough to
survive your role will be one of
servitude you'll be enslaved by the
powerful simply to survive
right now there's a secret War being
fought on one side the p52s and a few wh
hat operators in the military and the
government steering us toward timeline
one the positive timeline on the other
side the p45s the Illuminati and the
world's Elites pushing us toward
timeline two the
apocalypse if you look for it you can
see them prepairing in all of history
there have never been more underground
bunkers being built it's said that
underneath Denver Airport will be their
new headquarters
this will be one of the many safe places
around the world where those in power
can wait out the coming storm oh we're
not one of those people are we we are
not and neither are you if we end up on
the wrong timeline we're doomed timeline
One Peace compassion and kindness
timeline two chaos war and
hatred which path do you think we're
on the story of project Looking Glass
comes from three whistleblowers Bob
Lazar Bill wood and Dan burish most of
today's story was from Dan and it has
everything time traveling aliens
fighting for the future of humanity I
mean it's a ride but is it true well the
stories like this you know time travel
to the Future you can't really debunk
them at least not fully but we can look
at the people telling the story first
off this episode was difficult to write
because a lot of the stories contradict
each other our humans from Earth and we
eventually leave and become P whatevers
or humans were brought here from
somewhere else there are contradictions
Dan bur tells a wild story and he tells
it well and with feeling but he has his
detractors before he was Dan burish he
was Dan crane he says he worked at the
underground S4 lab near Area 51 this
place was made public by Bob Lazar Lazar
said anyone who believes this guy should
be ashamed of themselves he said he
never met this knucklehead knucklehead
his
Dan said that he worked with an alien
and they became friends he also said he
met angels in the lab and spoke to them
in Hebrew he claimed to be in the
military with the rank of Captain but
there's no record of that he said he got
his PhD in 1990 from Stonybrook
University in New York when Stony Brook
said they never heard of him he said
they covered up his records it was
discovered that during the time that he
said he was working at the S4 lab he was
actually working as a parole officer in
Las Vegas there's documentation to this
when that was uncovered he said that was
his cover job and he got his PhD by
flying back and forth to New York on the
weekends and the government paid for all
this Stony Brook said this is
ridiculous his finances show he wasn't
earning much money working at a top
secret lab he said he wasn't paid in
money but he was taken care of hey what
does that mean no idea he wasn't that
well taken care of he filed for
bankruptcy in 2002 his listed occupation
was Homemaker and he had assets of about
$300 plus one 199 97 Suzuki that wasn't
fully paid for now none of this means
he's lying but when you tell a story
like this people are going to pay
attention and they're going to look into
the person telling the
story as people looked into Dan he went
on the defensive over and over he's been
challenged by George Nory to take a lie
detector test he won't a lot of the
investigation was done by George knp
George knp knows his way around a UFO
story and he doesn't buy this
one really pisses me off
is when I get told what has or has not
happened to me by these people they have
no right to open their mouth I'm sorry
for screaming at you it sounds like Dan
is building off of Bob lazar's story he
also sounds like he built on the story
told by Bill U house who is the first to
mention jrods but Dan has added a lot of
Science Fiction tropes he's jammed so
many details into his story that it
reads like the syllabus for a conspiracy
course Illuminati every kind of alien
ever mentioned Men In Black bases on the
moon time travel lizard people lizard
and on and on I've noticed that many of
the people who tell these stories tend
to pack in all this stuff it makes it
harder to believe Bob Lazar doesn't
weave an elaborate tale about lizard
people Li it he talks about the projects
He personally worked on now you can
believe his story or not I find him one
of the more believable whistleblowers
and the time travel stuff doesn't make
sense Dan says there are timelines that
Branch off but the aliens come back and
time to affect their Future 1.21 gigatt
right if time travel works like the
movie Back to the Future then there's
only one timeline but he says there are
branching timelines in a Multiverse so
which is
it another reason to be skeptical is
Believers in this story say that the
chronovisor is a Looking Glass device
that's a machine that allows you to see
through time it's allegedly kept in the
Vatican secret archives it was developed
by father pelino ernetti in the early
1950s it's a good story and I link to a
video about it below father ernetti even
took pictures of Christ using the
chronovisor now I can't prove the
chronovisor is fake but I do know that
the pictures were
fake these same Believers also refer to
the book by Chan Thomas the Adam and Eve
Story the book describes a pole shift
apocalypse this was such a dangerous
book that it was allegedly classified by
the CIA and only a small portion of the
book has ever been seen well I've
covered the Adam and Eve story before
spoiler alert I debunk it so if
Believers of the project Looking Glass
story are using debunk stories as their
Foundation I'm already going in
skeptical on the other hand it's
interesting that Zeta reticuli and glea
came up Zeta reticuli is about 39 light
years away and the two stars are similar
to ours astronomers are looking for
exoplanets there because the system
might be able to support life but Zeta
reticuli was part of Betty Hill's
abduction story so it makes sense that a
hoaxer would add that detail but glea
was an interesting
choice glea 581 is a dwarf star about 20
light years away so relatively close
three exoplanets have been found there
and glea 581c is possibly in the
habitable zone and could support life at
the time it was called the most
earthlike of all known exoplanets it was
discovered in 2007 so maybe Dan heard
about it in the news but if he'd heard
about glea from an alien you'd think
he'd know how to pronounce it
in 2008 a radio signal was sent to glea
581c it's called a message from Earth or
AMF and it contains 501 different
messages the signal will reach the
planet in early 2029 just before the
next timeline switch Yeah I notice that
too whether you believe this specific
story or not I think you can feel that
something is happening I feel it Dan
story might be far-fetched but there's
plenty of evidence that the CIA and
other Black Ops programs have experim
ented with psychics remote viewing and
even time travel we know that they did
this so we have to stay diligent just in
case a timeline shift is coming so pay
close attention to the powerful Elites
which timeline are they steering us
toward the future is not just happening
the future is built by us by a powerful
Community as you here in this
room do they want us to have more
freedom more safety and more Unity or do
the elites and the media who serve them
want to remove our freedoms one by one
if we do as we're told Humanity will
finally be United live in peace and
prosper well that's what they
say do you feel safer today than a few
years ago do you feel more united with
people is the earth a peaceful place
2030 is only a few years away and it's
coming fast but we still have time we
still have a chance to steer Humanity
toward the positive timeline the
powerful don't want that to happen they
want us to hate each other and destroy
each other they want chaos and War and
ideally a World War and From the Ashes
and Rubble of their War they will build
a new world their world without us
whether you believe the two timeline
story or not something is happening the
lines have been drawn and it's time for
you to pick
aide
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's Heckle
fish and SLI me some fin yet this has
been the wi files if you had fun or
learned anything do us a favor subscribe
comment like share that stuff really
helps us out and like most topics we
cover on the channel today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the Wi files.com tips and remember
the yfiles is also a podcast twice a
week I post deep dives into the stories
we cover here on the channel I also post
episodes that wouldn't be allowed on the
channel it's called the wi files
operation podcast and it's available
everywhere you get your podcasts now if
you need more wi- files in your life
check out our Discord server there are
thousands of people on there 24/7 and
they're into the same weird stuff that
we are it's a great Community it's a lot
of fun and it's free to join and special
thanks to our patrons who make
everything possible every episode is for
you I don't deserve your support but I'm
truly grateful for it and if you'd like
to support the channel consider becoming
a member on patreon for as little as
three bucks a month you get access to
perks like the videos early without
commercials access to merch that's only
available to Members Plus you get two
private live streams every week just for
you another great way to support the
channel is grab something from the wifi
store go get some of these new Heckle
fish cards each card has a character
from the show the game is fun the cards
look great they feel good in the hand or
the fin and they're cheap uh you mean
inexpensive what I say that's going to
do it until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are are appreciated I
can't call them nobody's going
[Music]
to
yeah I play Bia in Area 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so I'm singing like I
should then another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my
friends and it never ends know it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's ho with mkl truck up being
only to
aware did Stanley curi fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there the r well aliens just fought the
smiling man I'm
told and his name was cold and I
can't I'm dancing with the
fish fish on Thursday night J
when to the
night all ever what it was you just see
the truth to one Fe all through the
[Music]
night
the M man Sid and the solar stor still
come to a go the secret City
Underground mysterious number stations
Planet are to project State and where
the dark Watchers
[Music]
found a simulation don't you
wor the black KN satell lighted to me so
I can't me I'm dancing with the
fish fish on thday night
J through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the TRU
the all through the
night night with they J and me all
through night
all I ever want to just hear the truth
so all to
the
love love dance good dance good dance
good Lov to
dance C lovees to dance on the dance
ball because she is is a camel when
camels love to dance when the feeling is
right on was in
time
love
[Music]